bienvenue s'est confiné d'ici et
d'ailleurs et aujourd'hui je vous emmène
dans une destination qui fait rêver nous
partons émirats arabes unis et plus
précisément à dubaï pour y rencontrer
audrey cabale salubre et merci nous
emmener aussi loin de chez nous on est à
dubaï
[Musique]
pourquoi dubaï ainsi que je suis parti
en vacances en 2007 dont la première
fois mais j'ai adoré et je suis reparti
en me disant que ce que je viserai la
marge est badin rêve c'est devenu un
projet qui s'est réalisé voilà j'ai
choisi dubaï parce que c'est un pays qui
bouge tout les cas si je puis dire de
magic liste c'est un pays où encore
rencontrer des personnes de toutes les
nationalités toutes les cultures toutes
les religions c'est un pays aussi mme
lemahieu moment idéal il fait beau toute
l'année vraiment la situation
géographique aussi puisque moi
partout c'est entre l'asie l'europe et
l'afrique
nous lui connaissons dubaï enfin je
parle surtout pour moi un camp photos à
travers les images qu'on voit sur les
réseaux sociaux et tout ça ça a l'air
d'être vraiment magnifique et
gigantissime en même temps ce qu'on est
dans le désert dubaï un donc ça c'est
beau c'est des building au beau milieu
du désert ont souligné ces basses et que
des petits toute aide est bâti de rien
du tout c'est ce que j'ai investi tout
et tout ils ont même créé une île
ils ont créé sur sur l'autre c'est
vraiment vraiment demeurer en parler du
confinement un petit peu avant de
revenir à dubaï est justement à de tout
ce qui fait rêver à dubaï on va voir des
photos des vidéos et tout ça des choses
qui nous donneront envie d'y aller j'en
suis sûr
comment se passe le confinement à dubaï
s'il y en a parce qu'il ya des pays où
où les choses sont gérées différemment
il n'y a pas de confinement où ça se
passe plutôt bien on continuera
responsabilité des gens à dubaï aussi
c'est comme ça où est ce que il ya un
confinement qui est stricte 24 heures
sur 24 7 jours sur 7
comprenant deux semaines ça s'est
terminé il ya une semaine donc là le
confinement
on a une tranche horaire sur laquelle
poivre une autorisation pour sortir
actuellement qui est deux entre dijon ce
soir 22h et 6h du matin mais si on peut
sortir les magasins d petit à petit on
plane au supermarché en peine centre
commercial tous les magasins sont tous
les lieux publics aussi ne sont pas
claires mais petit à petit la vie
reprend petit à petit mais est ce que tu
sais s'il ya beaucoup de d'antillais de
martiniquais guadeloupéens de duy anh
est également du côté de dubaï qui
vivent en tout cas c'est tellement tu
sais qu'après cette émission forcément
on a envie d'aller visiter dubaï
qu'est-ce qu'il faut absolument voir
vous faire là-bas tout un tas de choses
à faire
bien sûr ça dépend des intérêts de tout
un chacun
certaines personnes il adore le foot
féminine de dubaï d'autres moindre com -
forcément les choses habituelles
mon jetage pas qu'il allait encore une
fois la plus grande tour du monde garde
à la fllash l'amérique evans qui a aussi
annoncé dans un autre émirat à une heure
de la grande mosquée qui masque était
vraiment magnifique c'est vraiment à
voir
il ya aussi des parts des cadeaux pour
les enfants jusqu'à nous il ya vraiment
pour eux qu'est ou pour l'écrit tard les
bains venir alors soirée dans une boîte
de nuit différents tous les jours ça
aussi c'est pas vraiment et du contre
voit plus du tout aux antilles ça y est
vraiment j'adore les antilles prévoyait
d'y venir très bientôt quatre en tout
cas merci à toi nous avoir fait rêver
non fait visiter un petit peu dubaï à
travers les photos et tout ça qu'ils
nous envoient et puis la façon dont tu
en penses à l'air d'être vraiment une
belle destination à découvrir en
vacances ou peut-être pour y vivre ça
donnera peut-être des envies on sait
comment mais aussi audrey prends soin de
toi et à très bientôt aux antilles cette
fois voilà une nouvelle destination
qu'on rajoute à notre carnet de voyage
confiné d'ici et d'ailleurs est
maintenant terminée on se retrouve très
vite sur la première
[Musique]